what I want to do in this video is give
an overview of quadrilaterals and you
can imagine from this prefix or the I
guess you could say the beginning of
this word quad this involves four of
something and quadrilaterals as you
could imagine are our shapes and we're
going to be talking about
two-dimensional shapes that have four
sides and four vertices and four angles
so for example one two three four that
is a quadrilateral that lasts I didn't
look too straight one two three four
that is a quadrilateral one two three
four these are all quadrille arms they
all have four sides four vertices and
clearly four angles one angle two angles
three angles and four angles here you
could measure actually let me draw this
one a little bit bigger because it's
interesting so in this one right over
here you have one angle two angles three
angle and then you have this really big
angle right over there if you look at
the if you look at the interior angles
of this quadrilateral now quadrilaterals
as you can imagine can be subdivided
into other groups based on the
properties of the quadrilaterals and the
main subdivision of quadrilaterals is
between concave and convex
quadrilaterals so you have con cave and
you have convex and the way I remember
concave quadrilaterals or airily concave
polygons of any number of shapes is that
it looks like something has caved in so
for example this is a concave
quadrilateral it looks like this side
has been caved in and one way to define
concave quadrilaterals so let me draw it
a little bit bigger so this right over
here is a concave quadrilateral is that
it has an interior angle it has an
interior angle that is larger than 180
degrees so for example this interior
angle right over here is larger is
larger than 180 degrees it's an
interesting proof maybe I'll do a video
it's actually pretty simple proof to
show that if you have a concave
quadrilateral if at least one of the
interior angles has a measure larger
than 180 degrees that none of the sides
can be parallel to each other the other
type of quadrilateral you can imagine is
what
all of the interior angles are less than
180 degrees and you might say what
happens at 180 degrees well if this
angle was 180 degrees and these wouldn't
be to different sides it would just be
one side and that would look like a
triangle but if all of the interior
angles are less than 180 degrees then
you are dealing with a convex
quadrilateral so this context cut a
quadrilateral would involve that one and
that one over there so this right over
here is what a convex quadrilateral this
is what a convex quadrilateral could
look like four points four sides four
angles now within convex quadrilaterals
there are some other interesting
categorizations so now we're just going
to focus on convex quadrilaterals so
that's going to be all of this space
over here so one type of convex
quadrilateral is a trapezoid a trapezoid
and a trapezoid is a convex
quadrilateral and sometimes the
definition here is a little bit
different people will use different
definitions so some people will say a
trapezoid is a quadrilateral that has
exactly two sides that are parallel to
each other so for example they would say
that this right over here this right
over here is a trapezoid where this side
is parallel to that side if I give it
some letters here if I call this
trapezoid a-b-c-d we could say that
segment a-b is parallel to segment DC
and because of that we know that this is
that this is a trapezoid now I said that
the definition is a little fuzzy because
some people say you can have exactly one
pair of parallel sides but some people
say at least one pair of parallel sides
so if you say the if you use the
original definition and that's the kind
of thing that most people are referring
to when they say a trapezoid exactly one
pair of parallel sides it might be
something like this but if you use the
broader definition of at least one pair
of parallel sides then maybe this could
also be considered a trapezoid so you
have one parallel parallel sides like
that and then you have another pair of
parallel sides like that so this is a
question mark where it comes to a
trapezoid a trapezoid is definitely this
thing here where you
have exactly one pair of parallel sides
depending on people's definition this
may or may not be a pet trapezoid if you
say it's exactly one pair of parallel
sides this is not a trapezoid because it
has two pairs if you say at least one
pair of parallel sides then this is a
trapezoid so I'll put that in a little
question mark there but there is a name
for this regardless of your definition
of what a trapezoid is if you have a
quadrilateral with two pairs of parallel
sides you are then dealing with a
parallelogram so the one thing that you
definitely can call this is a
parallelogram parallel o parallel o
parallelogram parallelogram and I'll
just draw it a little bit bigger so it's
a quadrilateral if I have a
quadrilateral and if if I have two pairs
of parallel sides so two or the opposite
sides are parallel so that side is
parallel to that side and then this side
is parallel to that side there you're
dealing with a parallelogram and then
parallelograms can be subdivided even
further they can be subdivided even
further if the four angles in a
parallelogram are all right angles
you're dealing with a rectangle so let
me draw one like that so if the four
sides
so from parallelogram so these are this
is all in the parallelogram universe
what I'm drawing right over here this is
all the parallelogram universe so the
parallelogram tells me that opposite
sides are parallel and then if we know
that all four angles are 90 degrees and
we've proven in previous videos how to
figure out the sum of the interior
angles of any polygon and using it same
method you could say that the sum of the
interior angles of a rectangle of any
quadrilateral is actually a huh it's
actually 360 degrees and you see that in
this special case as well but maybe
we'll prove it in a separate video but
this right over here we would call a
rectangle parallelogram opposite sides
parallel and we have four right angles
now if we have a parallelogram where we
don't necessarily have four right angles
but we do have where we do have the
lengths of all the sides being equal
then we're dealing with a rhombus so let
me draw it like that so it's a
parallelogram this is a parallelogram so
outside is parallel to that side this
side is parallel to that side and we
also know that all four sides have equal
length so this sides length is equal to
that sides length which is equal to that
sides length which is equal to that size
length then we are dealing with a
rhombus so one way to view it all rhombi
are parallelograms all rectangles are
parallelograms all parallelograms you
cannot assume to be rectangles all
parallelograms you cannot assume to be
rhombi now something can be both a
rectangle and a rhombus so let's say
that this is the universe of rectangles
so the universe of rectangles a little
bit of a Venn diagram here is that set
of shapes and the universe of rhombi is
this set of shapes right over here so
what would it look like well you would
have four right angles and they would
all have the same length so it would
look like this so definitely be a
parallelogram it would be a
parallelogram for right angles for right
angles and all the sides would have the
same length and you probably this is
probably the first of the shapes that
you learned or one of the first shapes
this is clearly a square so all squares
are both rhombi are members of the they
can also be considered a rhombus and
they could also be considered a
rectangle and they could also be
considered a parallelogram but clearly
not all rectangles or squares or and not
all rhombi are squares and definitely
not all parallelograms are squares this
one clearly right over here is neither a
rectangle nor rhombi nor a square so
that's an overview just gives you a
little bit of text taxonomy of
quadrilaterals and then in the next few
videos we can start to explore them and
find their interesting properties or
just do interesting problems involving
them